in the last video we did an energy
calculation for an even-numbered fatty
acid and this one we're going to do it
for an odd number of carbons for a fatty
acid now the reason this is a little bit
different is because the last round of
beta oxidation does not yield an acetyl
co a instead we have a three carbon
molecule left at the end that three
carbon molecule is called propanil Co a
so we have a three carbon molecule
called propane yoco a now this is
something we haven't actually seen yet
this three carbon proprio Co a needs to
be converted to suck Co Co a which we've
seen before
we have seen this before so let's in
Ocoee a something is an intermediate in
the TCA cycle which can yield us some
energy well if it goes to the Krebs
cycle of course so what we need to do is
we need to take proprio co a and convert
it always sucks in Ocoee so that process
requires a few things first and foremost
probably no co a is a three carbon
molecule while sucks no Khloe is a
four-color molecule so propene Eelco a
we need to add a carbon to it so that's
going to cost us that's going to
actually excuse me not cost us we're
going to add a carbon dioxide to
propanol CO a and adding adding a a
carbon dioxide to you know in a reaction
to a particular molecule is not a very
simple task because the gas typically so
it's going to cost us energy so when it
cost us at an ATP just gonna go from ATP
to adp and the enzyme that actually does
this is called propane Eelco a
carboxylase and since the carboxylase
this enzyme will require biotin okay
once once we do that we create a methyl
Melanie Ocoee which is a four carbon
molecule that is then converted into
sectional Kawai and the enzyme that does
that is called methyl Melanie ole Co a
mutase so now
once we have the sectional code where
does this go well we've answered that
already and we go to the TCA cycle when
it goes to the TCA cycle what does it
give us the 16 Alcoa will give us
everything that's produced after it so
what we'll get from this we'll get one
GTP we'll get one fadh2 and one NADH
okay so once we put succinylcholine to
the TCA cycle it'll react all the way
until until it's converted back into
oxaloacetate which is what we started
with right so in that process we're
going to get a GTP fadh2 NADH if you
don't believe me go back through and
watch the TCA cycle videos to refresh
your memory so let's do the example if
we had a nineteen carbon fatty acid what
would happen how would we calculate the
amount of energy we get from it so first
and foremost it's a fatty acid so we
need to convert it into an acyl Co way
to activate it so that's going to cost
us two ATP then we can go through beta
oxidation so beta oxidation we clip off
two carbons at a time one two three four
five six seven eight eight rounds and
then we're left with this three carbons
here okay so we have eight rounds of
beta oxidation so eight cycle is a bit
of oxidation that we're going to
consider and then how many acetyl co
ways we make 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 acetyl co
is and then right here right here we
have 1 propene Eelco a so now let's
let's figure this all out for this
equation that I've written here ok so we
have a 19 carbon a so Co a going through
8 cycles of beta oxidation so it's going
to require each each one of these rounds
will require one of each of these these
things we have here coenzyme a and u
plus an F ID
so these NAD+ and FIDs will be converted
into nadh and fadh2 so we'll have eight
of each of those how many pseudocode
ways do we get what we underwent when we
underwent eight rounds we had eight
acetyl co ways and then we have 1
propene Yokoi way so these things go to
the electron transport chain right to be
reoxidized so we'll just count those
here as 8 NADH is an 8 fadh2 is that
work out or we'll add to everything else
in just a moment these are sido Koei's
go to the TCA cycle write the Krebs
cycle and of course each round 3 and a
th's 1 fadh2 1 GTP that's for one acetyl
co a there's eight of them that we have
here so we're gonna multiply each of
these numbers by eight and we get 24 and
a th's eight fadh2s and eight GTP's so
now where does this propio co egg go
well we just said that it has to be
converted into sucks no co a that's
going to cost us one ATP right and then
the sucks no co2 the TCA cycle where it
gives us one nadh one fadh2 and one GTP
so now we're going to add up all these
values so the total number of nadh as we
get we have 24 plus 1 plus 8 which is 33
33 nadh --is and we have 17 fadh2s
and nine GTP's if you multiply all those
values out we get eighty two point five
twenty five point five and nine if you
got all those values up you gross 117
ATP now we net 114 ATP why is that well
we subtracted two for activation because
we started off with a fatty acid right
we started I told you we started off
with a fatty acid not an acyl Co a so we
have to make sure that we take into this
a
into account I mentioned it in the last
video you wouldn't have to consider you
won't have to subtract this to ATP here
if you will calculating the amount of
energy we get from an acyl Co a ok but
where that still would leave us with
with 115 ATP
we also subtracted one from going from
propanil Co a - sucks in Ocoee right
that process costed us one ATP so we net
114 ATP overall if I had asked you for
419 carbon a so CO a instead the net
would have been how much well it would
have been 116 ATP right because we
wouldn't have 2 SEC we wouldn't have to
subtract this the 2 ATP for activation
but we would still have to convert that
last that last product that three carbon
molecule that pro pineal go away into
suction alcoa that would still have to
happen so we still have to subtract one
ATP to net 116 ATP but in any case I
hope that was helpful and thank you for
watching